welcome back America Stephen Miller
the lack of this Administration between
enforce federal law is that not a
violation of the Constitution as well as
Federal statutes are those not
impeachable offenses and are these not
policies that are intended to um
fundamentally undermine and unravel the
Civic structure of this country yes yes
and yes
first they are patently unconstitutional
the core constitutional command that
binds the hands of the executive is to
take care that the laws be Faithfully
executed this is the center of our
design between Congress the judicial the
executive branch what this president has
done is he has turned Congress into a
mere suggestion box the entire
immigration and nationality act which
governs who can enter our country how
you apply for a Visa what rules you have
to comply with where you have to apply
from that entire system has been
rubbished and Trashed by this President
as though he were an emperor and so it
is completely impeachable my
organization has been involved in a
number of lawsuits against his policies
and in each of those lawsuits we lay out
how he has violated the clear command of
Congress and the clear command of the
Constitution one of those cases that we
litigated uh in partnership with Texas
we won on title 42 another one with
respect to Immigration and Customs
Enforcement he's been found to have
broken the law again and again and again
and so yes these are impeachable crimes
absolutely especially because he has not
comply with the court injunctions when
he loses these lawsuits as is the case
in MPP or the remain in Mexico program
led by Texas now as to what the goal is
here it's to destabilize the middle
class
for the party of big government for the
party of Marxism
destroying the American middle class and
the social cohesion of a strong middle
class
makes it possible to have this big
government apparatus
the whole choice in our country is
between a a family structure and a
community structure at the center of
American life or government so look at
what happened to Los Angeles and
California with unending large-scale
legal immigration it ruined the public
schools it increased massively demand
for public services it ruined the Health
Care System it ruined the job market all
of these things collectively turned it
into a big government state because the
system isn't working so your health care
isn't working your job market isn't
working your wages aren't Rising
crime is is destabilizing the family so
government is going to step in and we're
going to be the parent and we're going
to be the provider for the people and so
that is absolutely the goal here is to
destroy the middle class and in turn the
whole American system and the whole
American value set does it not
Amaze you even though uh it's hard to
get amazed anymore
um
that the Democrat Party the vast
majority of it has embraced this entire
agenda
uh the so-called moderate Democrats some
of them are now speaking out because
they're trying to save their political
skin
but that the Congress and control the
Democrats both branches has taken
absolutely no steps not a single step
to give relief to the American people to
support federal law enforcement On the
Border
or even to start to prevent all the
drugs all the all the horrific sexual
activity all the illegal immigration
that's taking place not a single step
there's I mean and to your point the sex
trafficking the trafficking of minors
the number of minors who've been
smuggled and trapped across our borders
is double the highest level recorded in
all of history
this is a mark of everlasting shame on
every Democrat in Congress every one of
them because not a single one of them
has stood up and said until you secure
the Border until you stop Catch and
Release you don't have my vote on
anything because that's how you'd fix it
if Mark Kelly had a decent principled
bone in his body then he would say Mr
President you don't have my vote on your
Supreme Court nominee or any nominee or
any Bill until you stop this assault on
the people of Arizona anyone can send a
press release it means nothing it means
nothing action is what matters and all
we've seen is accommodation and
complicity from Democrats in Congress
and a footnote we don't see much
different from the leadership of the
Republican Party in the Senate Mitch
McConnell he could put the brakes on a
number of things
and he doesn't he talks he issues press
releases and on the whole they go along
in my opinion
Stephen Miller founder of American first
legal a wonderful organization keep up
the good work and God bless you my
friend God bless you thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else